dieses video wird gesponsert von lifta
fischer ja genau die zwei millionen euro
für das product placement in dem
crafting ideen video werden dann
übermorgen bei wiesn richtig nein spaß
beiseite freunde wir kommen nicht
willkommen sondern willkommen zu einer
neuen folge minecraft kräftigen ideen
ich habe heute nur drei crafting ideen
am start was sie wahrscheinlich schon im
titel gelesen habt weil ich einfach
extrem wenig weit habe aber wir fangen
mit der ersten sache die ich schon
eingeblendet und zwar wurde mir die
zugesendet von oli king lp eine richtige
uhr mit richtiger zeitgleich eisen es
gleich stock gleich glas eeg egs ge ge
sind jetzt schon das crafting rezept
eingeblendet und zwar sie das halt so
aus wie er mir das beschrieben hat bzw
wie es halt grad eingeblendet sehen zwar
hat man in den ecken jeweils ein eisen
dazwischen ein glas und in der mitte
einen stock und dann bekommt man eine
sepia farbene uhr heraus die von dem
design eigentlich der normalen minecraft
work genau gleich aussieht nur die hat
man quasi um den abend um den rechten
arm der die figur so immer im bild hat
wenn ihr versteht was ich meine da ist
dann halt einfach hier sonne uhr drum
und die zeigt nicht die minecraft zeit
sondern die zeigt die echte zeit das
heißt in der zeit wo ich das video
aufnehmen ist es gerade drei uhr 28 und
ich muss morgen 8 uhr aufstehen aber das
kann euch egal sein hauptsache das video
kommt ich mich wieder total fertig und
auch immer diese softbox diese zehn
milliarden watt die dichte einfach an
leuchten
was genau watt leuchten ein auch an luca
17 millionen licht partikel kacke da das
ist heller als die sonne ohne spaß es
ist so hell und jetzt auch noch mit
einer nacht naja jedenfalls ist das
crafting nummer eins wenn ich richtig
cool werden so was man minecraft
hinzugefügt wird weil also wenn man dann
nach halt wirklich auch so ein countdown
stellen könnte oder soweit überlegt mal
zum beispiel bei einem projekt wo man
nicht automatisch nach 15 minuten vom
server gekickt wird wie das bei warder
falle sondern wo du einfach nur fünf
minuten aufnehmen darf es aber nicht
diese server kick plugin hat kann man
dann einfach sagen okay fünf minuten
zeit stellen dann wimmelt diese uhr
quasi im spiel und so dass auf jeden
fall richtig cool oder wenn man was im
ofen hat dann kann man sagen okay dann
und damit dass wenn ich jetzt sollte
alle haben stellt und so man hat quasi
man diese uhr dabei und kann sich die in
verschiedenen designs holen dass wir auf
jeden fall richtig frosch die nummer
zwei wurde mir zugesendet von kaan kus
schreibt eine wasser spitzhacke weil man
unter wasser langsam baut und das
crafting rezepte cbc wss ich habe es so
interpretiert dass gleich eisen ist wie
gleich wasser und es gleich ein stock er
werde jetzt schon das crafting rezepte
eingeblendet also oben links und oben
rechts jeweils seien reisen also
eigentlich vom kräftigen rezept genauso
wie wenn man sich eine eisen spitzhacke
machen möchte nur oben in der mitte
statt dem dritten reisen dann einfach
ein wassereimer der quasi für diese
wasser affinität sorgen soll und die ist
so von einer schnelligkeit genau gleich
wie eine eisen spitzhacke nur ist die
wird ich jetzt mal einfach sagen an land
ist langsamer als eisen und unter wasser
ist es schneller als als also unter
wasser er geht sie genauso wie eisen
spitzhacke an land das tut nur an land
ist sie zwar nicht so langsam wie eisen
spitzhacke unter wasser aber auf jeden
fall halte die sonne mische ich glaub
ihr wisst was ich euch sagen möchte
jedenfalls ist das design so ein
bisschen zu an farben ich hab da ein
bisschen was gepixelt und das einfach
mal eingefügt dies sieht dann so ein
bisschen boshaft aus und damit kann man
unter wasser ganz coole sachen abbauen
und das fiel nicht echt sollte auf jeden
fall mal kommt danke an kalkül clevere
für den kräftigen ideen vorschlag
logitech tv schreibt ein spoiler drei
punkte wenn man den an ein minecraft
oder an einen minecraft einem ein
kartoffel wenn man den anderen mine card
oder an ein boot packt fährte schneller
gleisen stecken gleich nicht sie sind
jetzt schon das kräftige eingeblendet
und zwar an ja ich kann nicht so gut
pixeln das recht soll ein spoiler sei
naja jedenfalls hat man obendrein eisen
und links und rechts am rand ein stock
die quasi diese halterung für den
spoiler darstellen und ein spoiler ist
ja eigentlich dazu da wie beispielsweise
bei formel-1-autos dass sie bei den
hohen geschwindigkeiten nicht auf einmal
losfliegen in die lohner durch den
luftwiderstand dass die lüfter durch
verwirbelt wird und dadurch bleiben die
auf dem boden
deswegen kann man eigentlich durch einen
spoiler nicht schneller werden sondern
höchstens langsamer oder am boden
gehalten werden aber es wäre auf jeden
fall eine ganz coole sache wenn man sich
sonst boiler kräften könnte
der wird dann am boot hoch stechen das
wird einerseits richtig stylisch
aussehen und da aber halt beim ein kart
und man könnte dann einfach schneller
fahren obwohl beim einkauf schneller
fahren stelle ich mir ein bisschen
komisch vorbei wenn man ganz viele
rexhepi tat ist man eh schon extrem
schnell aber ich würde auf jeden fall
sagen bei dem boot wäre es richtig
richtig cool das war es dann auch schon
mit dieser folge der minecraft crafting
ideen viele hatten mich gefragt hey luca
machst du auch sonnen bit.ly
schrägstrich crafting ideen msc formular
wo man mir da die kräftige hin zu senden
kann
nie werde ich nicht machen weil ich das
einfach weiterbilden kommentare mache
weil mit dem mit den kräftigen es halt
die sache viele schreiben etwas sehr
sehr langes oder unter bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla also ich find's einfach
ganz cool wenn man das weiter über die
kommentare macht weil bei den
kommentaren ist es ganz simpel einfach
der einzige grund eigentlich ist das ihr
selber auch auf die kommentare eingehen
könnte ich hatte jetzt schon bei vielen
folgen einfach kräftige den am start wo
jemand eine kräftige geschrieben hat und
ich darf mir das total affig aber jemand
anderes hat die kräftige die
aufgeschnappt und ihm geantwortet oder
gesagt hey mach das das uns so dann habe
ich einfach beide kommentaren mit
rangenommen dachte okay das ist richtig
geil an dass er auch selber
untereinander interagieren können finde
ich richtig gut deswegen einfach wenn
die kraft gehabt und in kommentare
schreiben und es tut mir leid dass nur
drei crafting gehen waren das nächste
mal gibt's wieder 5 ich habe einfach nur
richtig wenig zeiten ich bin müde und
ich muss schlafen und wir sehen uns in
einem nächsten video wie tief